[Musik]
hallo meine lieben heute machen wir mal
eine bananen brot warum machen wir das
sagt biran schuld wenn ich hab euch in
der story gezeigt auf instagram dass ich
überreife bananen habe und eigentlich
mag ich dir in die so sind dann sind sie
nämlich richtig süß aber ich irgendwie
hatte ich keine lust jetzt so zu essen
motto du gar nicht da haben sie sind so
unterschiedlichen doch sogleich auf
jeden fall mache ich da raus jetzt
bananen brot auf euren wunsch hin und
ich habe da jetzt ein paar zutaten sag
ich mal ausgetauscht damit ist etwas
gesünder als ich mache das jetzt hier
mit der küchenmaschine könnte neuer
handrührgerät verwenden und ich geb dir
jetzt zuallererst eier hinzu ist es
besser wenn die zimmer waren sind da
gebe ich jetzt dazu alle mengenangaben
unten in der video beschreibung guter
hinweis da gebe ich jetzt noch kommt
rein dass es birken zucker hat 40
prozent weniger kalorien als
haushaltszucker ihr könnt aber auch eins
zu eins haushaltszucker nimm den
gewöhnlichen den ihr kennt mich da jetzt
auch noch mit dazu
dann für den geschmack vanille extrakt
und ziemlich finden sind passt wunderbar
dabei könnte in zimt auch weglassen so
und dann fahren wir dass drei minuten an
[Musik]
die eier zucker masse wird jetzt drei
minuten lang auf allerhöchster stufe
gemixt mit richtig schön voluminös und
ganz zum schluss gebe ich ganz kurz nach
der sonnenblume dazu da könnt ihr es
doch rapsöl nehmen oder wenn ihr möchtet
gerne auch kokosöl und im nächsten
schritt kommt es mit dazu ich habe jetzt
hier mehl und backpulver mail ist bei
mir ganz normales weizenmehl für eine
noch gesündere variante könntet ihr zum
beispiel dinkelmehl neben typ 630 könnt
ihr hier eins zu eins ersetzen oder ihr
nehmt ein drittel krokus mail
das könnt ihr auch gerne nehmen ist auch
super gesund also eigentlich gibt es
total viele varianten das ist jetzt hier
wie gesagt nur eine und es gebe ich es
noch dazu und siebe das dann habe ich
auch keine klümpchen im teig und dass
wir dann nur ganz kurz ein gerührt
[Musik]
im nächsten schritt gehen wie walnüsse
dazu könnte auch natürlich andere nüsse
nehmen einfach die die am liebsten mit
danach chocolate chance in zartbitter
ich liebe diese dicken fetten chocolate
chance stücke und anschließend noch
lauwarme milch die könnt ihr natürlich
auch schon vorher dazu geben sei es
meint weder das habe ich einfach
vergessen aber es macht den tag gibt
keinen abbruch also dem geschmack vor
allem nicht und da geben wir jetzt auch
noch klein geschnittene bananen rein wie
gesagt meiner meinung nach hier reifer
desto besser die gebe ich jetzt aber nur
noch in einem teig schaber in den tag
und dann können wir ihnen auch schon
backen unser bananen boot
[Musik]
jetzt schnappen wir uns eine kasten
kuchenform ich verlinke euch meine unten
in die video beschreibung und füllen den
teig einen davor gebe ich ganz gerne
noch backpapier rein damit man es ganz
einfach leichter rausbekommt gerne noch
voll mit ein bisschen back prinz bei
einsprühen anhaftet das auch wunderbar
und was ihr unbedingt machen ist mein
tipp für euch statt euch ein bisschen
braun zucker oder rohrzucker und gibt es
ganz dünn auf die oberfläche dann
karamellisiert das und ihr habt so eine
art kruste obwohl die ganze für machen
musste also wirklich nur ein bisschen
zucker darüber streuen und für die optik
und man auch weiß worum es sich handelt
noch eine banane einmal durchschneiden
in der mitte und oben in den teig
reindrücken und jetzt packen wir unser
bananen brot bei 180 grad ober und
unterhitze für circa 45 bis 50 minuten
eventuell auch 55 minuten da müsst
einfach selber schauen macht gerne die
stäbchen probe und falls euch das zu
dunkel wird gibt einfach ein bisschen
alufolie auf die oberfläche und dann
kann euch da eigentlich nichts schief
gehen wir sehen uns gleich wieder
[Musik]
und fertig ist das bein an brot das
riecht so gut das riecht so so gut ihr
könnt das jetzt entweder zum frühstück
mit einem belag drauf zum beispiel
schokocreme richtig lecker mit
schokocreme oder einfach so ohne alles
zum kaffee oder zum testen wie ihr
möchtet
und ihr habt auch hier diese leckere
kruste durch den rostocker das kommen
jetzt gerne mal zeigen
das hört man glaube ich auch also
leckere kruste und innen ist es halt
eher so ein bisschen softer und das hält
sich jetzt auch wenn es luftdicht
verpackt so circa 34 tage ganz frisch
schmeckt natürlich am allerbesten
wie gesagt die genauen mengenangaben
hier unten in der video beschreibung
einmal aufklappen anschauen und dann
einkaufen gehen und ansonsten abonniert
main kanal kostenlos aber passt ja auch
nichts mehr
die lasten deutlicher nach oben und dann
lesen wir hier unten in den kommentaren
von einander beschreiben miteinander und
den uns dann bewerten dies bereits
[Musik]